hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 22nd European
Team Championship it's Netherlands vs.
Spain onboard one it's an interior
versus David Anton de haro and a la
there's been a lot of talk about it
should be punished in some way or not
for declining to play in the Isle of Man
chess tournaments so as if he was
preserving his rating so he doesn't lose
his spot in the candidate so here it's
gonna be very interesting to see how he
will fare on board one will he lose
rating will he gain rating and again can
he improve on his rating even more or
will his candidate spot maybe fault
someone else like Maxie Marshall de
Graaff or or who knows you know what
else can happen but that being said
let's check out the game as it is a very
nice game give me already one a very
nice game in the previous round I was
thinking about showing it and I was
actually about to show it and then I saw
this game which just happened so I
decided to show this one instead as it's
also a very nice game so Gary would the
white pieces opens with E 4 with E 5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to c4
the Italian is on the board and Bishop
to c5 so here B 4 D Evans gambit really
an act and also move but it was not
played in this game so here we have
castles by Gary and now just nice to
have six with d3 the six by black with C
3 and a 5 this has been all played a lot
of times we look to e 1 and now castles
with h3 by Gary h6 by G Haro and now
Knight B to d2 this night is coming to
f1 at some point then either to e3 or
the g3 depending on what black plays
Bishop to e6 making room for the Queen
to go to b8 we already covered a few
games in this line the Queen wants to
come to BH day 7 and then from a7 with
the bishop put some pressure on the f2
pawn with Bishop to b5 now preparing to
capture then I can see 6 Queen to be 8
and now
Aggie her already had this position in
the aisle Manchester namond against
LaVon Oregon where Knights the f1 was
played but here Giri goes for Bishop
captures on c6 Giri follows his game
against ding from Shenzhen China with
beat captures on c6 and now d4 attacking
the bishop also expanding in the center
he captures seed captures and now in the
game against ding ding played Bishop to
b4 against Gary that game ended in a
draw but here Bishop to b6 it's not a
new move it has been played before but
here is where we have a completely new
move and a completely new game there is
a non move B 3 here and for example on
and defeated with it with Knights to f1
here in the top of still India Edition
but Giri goes a 4 here and it is as a
move 14 that we have a completely new
game so let's see what poison Giri
prepared for jihad the idea is he wants
to make a very nice rock lift with rook
to a3 followed by rook to e3 the idea
has never been tried before
we've looked by Haro and not rook to a3
giri just continues with his plan with
queen to be seven now and rook 8 III we
look a to b8 now doubling up on de and
the B file the the b-pawn might become a
bit weak will be 3 and now Russia back
to a7 so now this Knight is pretty much
stuck here guarding the b3 pawn but it's
also nice that the roku guarded so even
though it's attacked three times it
doesn't really matter because it's a
nicely defended but giri might have some
problems developing his pieces because
they are all stuck in guarding the b3
pawn now but okay worship the b2 by Giri
and now d5 kiharu invites giver to push
e5 with E 5 by giri
now weakening the center so he can later
undermine it with c5 with Knight to d7
and here Knights to h4 so what do you
play here best for gr o is Queen to h5
is coming by giri as he prepared for
this game to go for and for a nice
attack if possible the rook can also
come to g3 to join in the attack and
here you want to play Queen to b4 it
doesn't allow the Queen to jump into the
game because the knight will be hanging
and once the Queen is kicked away you go
back to e 7 and from e7 if
anything like Quinta Queen to h5 is
played you can always go Queen to g5 so
this is a the best way to go for black
but kiharu continued with c5 it's a very
principled move you want to strike in
the center you have a CC point why not
get rid of it but it's it's a problem if
it's too slow so here it goes
look the g3 and ok we have Queen to a6
now a move that will that guitarra will
pay dearly as the Queen is a really out
of game on a6 the idea is probably
somehow trying to want this Bishop moves
trying to get to the Queen into the game
this way or or or might be some other
idea can pinpoint it right away but
you'll see what I mean by this
a Geragos Queen to h5 and here we have
kinked h8 not allowing Queen captures on
h6 as the g7 point is pinned so King to
h8 and now Bishop to c1 Giri is now
ready to move the knight and then the
bishop will capture an h h6 if there is
very little you can do about this
because the light square bishop doesn't
really have anywhere to go and you don't
really have a good way of bringing your
Queen back into the defense or any other
pieces for that matter rub the g8 McGee
Haro
and now Knight d2 f3 preparing to
capture on age sex this is happening
there's no way you can prevent this we
have Knights the f8 bringing yet another
defender into the game but Bishop
captures on h6 so what do you do here of
course you could capture but that's not
really something you want to do if you
capture then Queen captures on h6 with
check your King has no moves you have to
you have to block with the night and
after nights the h7 you're gonna go
Knight to g5 and here again there really
aren't no good there are no good moves
here Queen captures on h7 the threat of
mate and well there just isn't all that
much you can play now you could go Queen
to d3 which might be one of the reasons
why he Hara decided to place the Queen
and ASIC that he might also try and get
her into the game but if this rook
wasn't in g3 so here yeah you don't
really have a move you could play
capture swans but after captures
captures there still there's no good way
to play this if ruby ghr just gonna cap
capture screen captures and just bring
the other rook into the game rookie
three and the rook g3 and that's just
game over
so not really something that is
difficult to calculate
so here g6 buggy Haro and now feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
best move for giri in this position
while i give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on continuing the attack
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course Knight
captures on g6 so what can you play here
with F captors and g6 at the point of
nightcap person g6 is the free dh4
square for whites Queen
so F captors and g6 and now Queen to h4
by giri and now the threat is just
Bishop captures an F 80 this will be
checkmate it's a discovered check from
the Queen and the bishop will still be
guarding the g7 square so nice the h7 by
G Haro and here giri just brought
another piece into the game he played
Knight to g5 and it was in this position
I move 28th that Davi D'Antoni Hara
resigned the game and that's another
victory in the 22nd European team
championship for onigiri so really a
really exciting stuff he resigned here
because if you capture the night and
Knight captures you just get Bishop
captures with to check and once the King
starts running away it's a really quick
mate Queen h6 checking f7 look f3 check
King has to run away and now Queen to h7
and there is no defense against Queen to
e7 mate you could you know play some
silly moves and prolong the mate but
Queen e7 meet is coming so after Knight
g5 you could try Ruby g7
maybe somehow run away with the king but
it's still the same idea but she
captures captures you're just gonna
capture here Queen King to a fate or
rook after rechecking it and now rook f6
is sufficient after rook captures on e6
it will either win the Queen or you are
very quickly getting checkmated so or
both you know why not but yeah now after
Knight to g5 another excellent victory
for gira in the 22nd i repeat even
championships so it seems that he I
think you won around for rating points
for this game and I think he won around
4 in the previous game and he started
with 2780 so if he continues this he
might go into
the into the candidates tournament being
rated 2800 but it's still early in the
in tournament we'll just have to wait
and see I don't know the other results
because this game finished and I
immediately decided to show it but I
will I will keep you informed on
understandings and on the other results
as we do have some other games to check
as well so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it it's been a while since we
saw a nice while the Giri game I would
like to thank a lot if they're already
at least Felipe VI Oh a Laurence
Cuthbert Bruce Moody and the Michael
Fallon for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
video Sierra thank you for watching and
I will see you soon
continuing to cover the 22nd european
team championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and still
preparing the next big saga well the
vote for it so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day